but how you buy a house in one day
for the people who don't understand the
business let's pretend that
you are a wholesaler and you have a
house
and a guy let's pretend you're next door
neighbor what's a wholesaler first of
all
a wholesaler is a guy who's in the
business who doesn't want to close
he just wants to assign his contract so
what that means is let's pretend this
phone is a contract
so you have a house for sale so you want
to sell a house for a hundred thousand
dollars
okay he gets the contract and he gets he
gets
an inspection period right so an
inspection period
in other terms is like let me get a few
days or a couple weeks so i can market
your property right to sell to a real
buyer
so they go to a title company and the
title work starts
going they do they check for mortgages
they check for liens and blah blah blah
so once the title company tells you yo
the property's ready to go
so you got a contract for 100 grand
let's just say yeah so you want to push
it on the street because you don't have
any money
but you want to make money because you
brought the deal right so then
you come and you push it around the
block you email blast it you do whatever
you got to do
you're pushing it for 120 130 whatever
you think you could get based on what
it's worth
so when that doesn't work they call a
guy like me hey brian i got a day left i
got to close it
where are you closing that give me the
name of the title company send me the
title commitment i look at the title
commitment
boom all right send me the underlining
contract so i look at the underlying
contract i see what they're paying i see
everything
so i go look at it so in tampa florida
where i live i know every street in town
so i already know what it's worth before
i get there so you're buying it for a
honey and i said cool i'll give you a
buck 10.
so it's up to you to sell it to me or
not so you can make 10 grand and you
didn't really do not except put up a
deposit
so i call the title company and i call
candice who runs my office
candice wire the money get this hud boom
so i go in there i don't even have to go
sign
i do docusign because i'm a buyer i'm
not a seller so they don't need a
notarized copy
so i buy the house in two three minutes
then what i do after i close
i give it to one of my team members so
they can re-push it
so that is one thing i wanted to see
because when i read the comments
let's look at these comments right here
sure go right ahead yo this guy in the
comments says i know a guy
won't mention his name he uses banks
well a lot of people use his banks but
i'ma tell you the reason why i
personally don't use banks you mean i
use owner finance but i'm gonna tell you
why i don't use banks
it's like this if you look at my track
record right and you see that i bought
thousands of houses but i bought them in
a day
and sold them the same day i pushed them
to hedge funds it's like this
let's say i'm buying a house that's
worth 200 000
by the time a bank gives me that loan i
already got it sold because i got to go
get an appraisal
i got to get a survey who has time for
that and if you got money in the bank to
copy who cares
because you're already trying to re-push
it you know what i'm saying if you're
gonna buy it
and retell it i mean those days are over
yeah
you're a different breed though bro well
you have to be a different breed if
you're like everybody else you ain't
gonna get nowhere
yeah that's true but no one can not
everybody can be like everybody
hustling not everybody everybody can be
a hustler though see a lot of people
hustle different things
some people hustle fish they go fishing
they pump the fish on the block
some people hustle retail you know they
sell cars
some people hustle fur coats back in the
day before you know the
the people started shaking because it's
not politically correct
but everything has a dollar trade value
some people hustle drugs
yeah be i never get into that because it
doesn't make sense there's less money in
that you're gonna do a bid
everybody's gonna get busted yeah
that's true but the bottom line is if
you want to make money
you have to have a good eye for what's
out there at the same time you have to
know who your client is
and you have to know how to buy because
like i told you from the rip
you only make money when you buy you
only realize
when you sell so what's the what's the
best way
if because right now the real estate
market's [ __ ] crazy you go if you see
a house for sale and you
are interested you want to go look at it
the day it goes on the market there's
probably are going to be 10 offers on
that house
so how do you get the [ __ ] how do you
get the deal when there's so much
competition for the deal
because you have to remember when it's
up for sale it's already with a real
estate agent
when it's with a real estate agent it's
already retail
because and then they're going to shoot
for highest and best and if you have
if you're a fha buyer or if you're a
conventional loan buyer they're going to
look at you last
they only want to deal with cash buyers
because they want to get out of there
right they don't want to fix it they
don't want to do nothing
but the problem is like if you're in the
city limits and you sell your house now
the odds of you moving back are very
very low because the houses are going to
go up
30 to 50 percent next year and i'll tell
you why if you want to know
yeah why yeah i definitely want to know
well because you have the liberal
communists in office right now
and what they're looking to do is take
1031 exchanges away so basically what a
1031 exchange is
let's say you buy a apartment building
for 10 million dollars or how whatever
and then you re-flip it and then you
take that money and put it into a
similar product
they're trying to take that away because
they want to eat your money
was it why the explain tax you want to
explain i understand what 1031 exchanges
i mean it makes a lot of sense it makes
a lot of sense for people
that are employing ridiculous amounts of
people
to be able to to do that to roll your
your profit into new deals without
paying tax on it it makes sense as an
incentive for people that always
remember you're always paying taxes no
matter what right no
i paid hundreds of thousand dollars a
year in real estate taxes no yeah for
sure i i completely understand how it
works
you're paying a shitload you're paying
tons of payroll taxes for all your
employees
when you're running that big of an
operation it makes sense as an incentive
to incentivize the people that have the
balls to take those risks
to buy those big ass [ __ ] deals so
why
would they want to remove that incentive
what is that what is the
percy not a political person and the
reason is because that doesn't make me
money it just causes enemies
because there's people on both sides of
the fence trying to fight you but i'll
tell you
my opinion the reason they need the
money to pay for what they're what
you know all the things that's happening
but i'm gonna tell you why
my thing is about real estate i'm gonna
tell you why the houses are gonna go up
and you could take this to the bank we
are in hyper inflation right now
if you ever if you go out to eat no
matter what you go with your girl you
get a drink no matter what is the worst
place in tampa or
saying p whatever you can drop a hundred
dollars minimum and
they want to raise the minimum wage to
15 so you know what they did
so what they did was they started paying
300 a week plus 275
so that's 575 a week and if you make 15
an hour times 40 hours at 600
minus taxes and blah blah blah so you're
making more money to stay at home
so basically you're forcing a minimum
wage hike
right so now the real estate is a
capital gains when you buy and sell real
estate you make capital gains not you're
not working a job
so if they raise the capital gains and
they eliminate 1031 exchanges
nobody who has any brains or cash is
gonna sell anything
what they're gonna do is they're gonna
build they're going to rent
they're going to refinance they're going
to take all their equity out
and they're going to rent airbnb or
they're going to rent to regular section
8
because section 8 is going to go up you
know section 8 you know where people get
paid to live for nothing
so all these all these rents are going
to skyrocket
and the real estate will go up because
you'll have less real estate to sell
that makes sense that makes total yeah
well that's where the market's at but
you want to be in the city limits
the money is always in the city there
was a guy over here i just want to say
i said i live in a 400 000 he doesn't
even know where i live because 99
of my assets are in trusts i just found
that funny
he said what some guy in the comments
said that i live in a 400 000 house
my funny thing is how does this guy know
where i live right it's irrelevant but i
just found that funny
do you live in a four hundred thousand
dollars i got a three thousand square
foot house on a lake and a good
neighborhood
yo the guy who said that i want to buy a
hundred of those for six hundred
thousand
bring them yeah i'm a cash buyer hurry
up anyway
i just wanted to touch on that this
this the type of guy who rips you off
and then disrespects you after
well i don't rip anybody off because i'm
gonna tell you straight up and down
when i do a deal i'm not gonna call you
on the phone i'm gonna look straight in
your eyes i'ma look at your soul i'm
gonna shake your hand
i'm gonna give you the money that you
want it's either this you want my bread
or you want your product
it doesn't matter to me because if you
don't want to sell this other girl sells
me
and when you want to sell to me go shop
it around because if you give it to a
wholesaler they're going to call me back
anyway
i think you need a vodka i've already
had about 40 today i'll take one right
now they're
actually drinking great goose yeah why
not let's get there i'll get you some
i'm sorry
keep scrolling a little bit yeah um i
got if you like this is uh
this is sparkling water straight away i
like the sparkling water that's good
right
liquid definitely murder your thirst
murder it
you gotta murk them they got good slogan
it's always about that catchphrase right
mm-hmm
anyway holla at me what else we got what
else we got let's see